Language learning starts with you,
with the person, with the learner.
Just do it!
Language learning to me is almost
like a model of life itself.
So many things can happen
to us in our lives.
What matters is what we do.
And when we start something,
that's the most important step.
To do something! And if we do
something, it may trigger a series
of events that we didn't anticipate.
Some might be better than we hoped
for, some might be worse than we
hoped for. But throughout my life,
every time I have undertaken to
do something, it has brought me
some of the greatest
opportunities in my life.
When I was, I think, 19,
working on a construction
site in Montreal, I was fired.
That particular section of the job had
been completed, so I went down to the
dock in Montreal, and for three days, I asked
to see the captain of the various ships
that were docked in Montreal Port.
I asked to work my way across to Europe.
Day three, I found work on a German
freighter called the Gerda Schnell.
And here you see a picture of
me with my crew members.
And I worked my way across to Europe.
I ended up in Grenoble in France.
And here is another situation.
I had a very good friend who was a Turkish
student whose name was Cağpar, and
I was studying English and French.
I didn't know what to study, but he
was studying political science.
So I switched over to political science
and the following year I went to
Sciences Po (Institut d'études politiques) in Paris, and got a
scholarship from the French government.
Eventually I wrote my foreign
service exam there for the Canadian
Diplomatic Service and was accepted.
So all of these things came from
my decision to go and hitchhike
on a boat across to Europe.
Similarly, when I was with the
diplomatic service, I heard that they
were looking for someone to study
Mandarin Chinese, because in 1968,
Canada was getting ready to recognize
the People's Republic of China.
They wanted to train some
people up in Chinese.
So I went and started
taking Chinese lessons.
I didn't learn very much.
But I told my boss, "Hey,
I am learning Chinese.
I'm your man."
Why wouldn't they choose me?
Next thing you know, I'm in Hong
Kong studying Chinese, prowling the
bookstores for material, reading and
listening and doing whatever I can.
I.
I mean, I can go on and on and on in
my professional career about things that
I did, whether it be in my diplomatic
career or in my career, first as a
forest industry executive, and then an
entrepreneur in the forest industry.
Very often it's not what I expected would
happen that ended up happening. But it
was the fact that I did something that
caused opportunities to come my way.
You know, it's a bit like the book that I
listened to and read in
Danish, "Live More, Think Less"
We are bombarded by thoughts all day long.
50,000 thoughts
apparently.
Some are good, some are bad.
Some people dwell on the negative thoughts
and some of them end up with depression.
It's how we choose to
deal with these thoughts.
It's our belief system that determines
how we cope with these thoughts.
And the same is true in language learning.
You know, you may not be tremendously
motivated to learn Spanish or Japanese,
and you start on it, and you may find
something there that motivates you to
continue. Or you may meet people through
having learned or studied that language.
It's just as possible that
you will be motivated then
to move to another language.
In other words, that initial
impetus to learn language
might lead you to learn language.
The important thing is to do something
to get started. As the French say, "l'appétit vient en mangeant"
So there are so many examples of
this in my life, but I thought
of it with specific reference to
language learning.
Many people say, "Well, I have no talent.
I was never any good."
Well, maybe you should
just give it a chance.
Push on it a little bit, see what happens.
Push on that door.
It may open, it may not. But maybe in
trying to learn this language, you'll
meet some people or you'll find another
language that interests you. Or even
something else unrelated to language.
But the main thing is, everything
that happens to us in our lives,
we're surrounded by opportunities.
But what matters is whether we do
something. And the more active we are,
the greater number of these opportunities
will come our way. Including the fact
that the more languages we know, the
greater the number of opportunities
that are going to come our way.
So I just wanted to talk a little
more generally about the importance
of being proactive in our lives.
"Do it!" as that Nike
advertising slogan went.
Thanks for listening.